So today we're going to continue our
focus on DNA which I'm personally
enthusiastic about at least in terms
of being such a fascinating molecule.
And I told you the story last time
of how we actually came to
understand that DNA was the genetic
material.  And I still see comments
that, oh, God,
all this stuff is not relevant to
the exam.  We're trying to construct
the exams in ways that test whether
you got the concepts and not just
whether you memorized every term
that you ran into in the textbook.
So I'm hoping that you will see some
greater purpose in why I'm trying to
talk about some of this.
And also I'm sure some of you will
forget the details of transformation,
of DNA replication we're going to go
into as we sort of burrow into it
over the next lecture or so,
but what I am hoping you may
remember ten years from now,
even those who don't go in biology,
is how experiments are done, how
real people do them.
And that was partly what I was
trying to tell you.
And you guys are pretty good at
figuring out the basic principle
that someone had to somehow show
that a DNA molecule in one organism
could change some organism to have a
new characteristic.
And as I sort of told you with the
work from Frederick Griffith.
And then his initial stuff wasn't
devoted to that at all.
It was trying to solve a very
pressing problem which is dealing
with pneumonia in a pre-antibiotic
era.
And then the finding that he got,
that this odd result that something
in a heat-killed extract could be
transferred to a live bacterium sort
of set things up for Avery and his
colleagues after a number of years
of work to make a very powerful
argument that DNA was the genetic
material.  But,
as I said at the end of last lecture,
that paper was published
in the 1940s.
And people didn't immediately say oh,
wow, DNA is the genetic material.
Often, and we'll see it again with
genetics, there's sometimes sort of
the body of science the average
person thinks about.
Science needs to reach to a certain
state before an idea can take hold,
even if there's evidence supporting
it.  Part of the problem was that
chemists had isolated DNA.
And the way they used to isolate DNA
was really rough on it.
Crack the cells open.  And what
happened, it would all get broken
down into little pieces of DNA.
And people had worked out the basic
chemical structure that it was the
deoxyribose and how the things were
joined together,
but nobody had ever seen anything
more than just these little pieces
of DNA.  And there was a widely held
conception that it was just an
anonymous tetranucleotide
of G, A, T and C.
It wasn't clear why the cells made
it, but it didn't look like anything
that could encode information.
Whereas, as I said, something like
proteins, those seem to be very
different.  And so the world wasn't
quite ready for it.
Another thing, and this came from
one of the comments here,
was someone said they didn't know
bacteria could take up DNA from the
environment.  And,
in fact, most bacteria can.
It happens that streptacoccucci and
some other bacteria at certain
phases in their lifetime develop
this capacity to take up
DNA from the outside.
Given what I've told you about a
membrane and how hard it is to get
things across it,
you could imagine it's not trivial
to get a DNA molecule which is huge
from one side to the other.
So it doesn't normally happen.
And what happens if you go into a
lab and you're cloning something or
other, and we'll talk about how to
take a couple pieces of DNA and join
them together in a test tube and
then put them back
into a bacterium.
If we put it into E.
coli that doesn't normally take up
DNA you'll find that it's sort of
basically black magic.
You cook them up with some divalent
cations at very high concentrations,
you do temperature shifts and
various things,
or you give them a big jolt of
electricity, and the next thing you
know you get some DNA inside.
And it's not a very efficient
process, but all you need is one
molecule to get in one bacterium and
then you're in business.
So that was another reason that
this wasn't accepted right away.
Because this was not a phenomenon
that could easily be repeated with
other bacteria.
So it looked like it was something
perhaps special to streptococcus.
And what did really change people's
understanding,
or at least bring people to the
understanding that DNA could
possibly be the genetic material
came about from the discovery of the
actual structure of --
How the structure of DNA as a long
molecule with complimentary strands
and the double helix,
the little pictures I showed you
with the base pairs,
which you know about,
and how the two strands which now
I'm going to start emphasizing run
in opposite directions.
We'll come back to that in a little
bit, but the 5 prime to 3 prime
direction is this way on one end and
5 to 3 on the other.
And just remember back here that
there's the 5 prime carbon and
that's the 3 prime carbon.
So this is the 5 to 3 prime
direction of the strand.
And then it twists up in
3-dimensional space to form this
double helix.  And you've seen that
movie several times.
So once that structure was
discovered then people began to see
how these could possibly encode
information.  It was clearly not
just a tetranucleotide
of G, A, T, Cs.
But we didn't move immediately to
that understanding.
And today, again sort of trying to
show you how biological experiments
are done and how they're done by
real people, I want to just go on
and tell you the key things that
happened next.
So someone who was very struck by
the results of Avery when they came
out was Erwin Chargaff who was at
Columbia.  And,
in fact, my colleague Boris
Magasanik whose office is next to
mine was a post-doc
in Chargaff's lab.
So I've got a neighbor of mine who
worked with Chargaff.
And Chargaff was very struck by
this result from Avery and his
colleagues that you could take DNA
and put it in another organism.
And here are a couple of quotes
from his writing.
One that I'd liked.
I've sort of had a sense of this in
my own research career,
this kind of thing.  ìI saw before
me in dark contours the beginning of
a grammar of biology.î
He didn't really know quite how it
worked but he sort of sensed that
someone here where you could get
down to the language that biology
was written.  So he started some
experiments.  And I started with the
conviction that if different DNA
species exhibited different
biological activities there should
exist chemically demonstrable
differences between deoxyribonucleic
acids.  So he was able to start just
doing some simple chemical
experiments to try and look at DNAs
from a whole variety of sources and
see what he could learn.
And this was not at the structural
level.  This was just at the
chemical level.
But one thing he learned was that
the base content of DNA,
that's the A, G, C, T part of it
varied widely between organisms.
So this was what Chargaff found in
his lab, key findings.
And that was important because if
DNA was just a molecule of GATC,
just a tetranucleotide that every
organism made then you'd expect to
find the same base composition in
all organisms.
He didn't, so that finding
essentially buried the monotonous
tetranucleotide hypothesis.
Another thing he found was that DNA
was the same in different
tissues --
-- from the same organism --
-- but the proteins varied.
And that's a characteristic you'd
expect of something that was the
genetic information from the cell
that all cells have to have sort of
the major blueprint.
And if you had, even though
proteins look like an attractive
possibility for that because they
had so much variation,
this kind of finding wasn't
consistent with it and it supported
the idea that DNA was the
genetic material.
Well, the other thing he could do
was he could measure the ATG and C
content of all these different DNAs.
And he noticed some similarities
then.  And he extracted out of that
a couple of generalizations.
One was that if you looked at the
ratio of the purines,
those are the ones with the two
rings, adenosine and guanidine over
the pyrimidines,
those are the ones with the single
ring which were C and T,
there are about one.
Another thing he noticed was that
the ratio of A to T was about one
and the ratio of G to C was about
one.  Now, that was an important
clue but it didn't lead to any
immediate breakthrough,
even though maybe now that you know
the structure you can see,
gee, if I had been there maybe I
would have been smart enough to jump
on that number.
So instead the work that led to the
structure of DNA now introduces a
couple of other characters who
you've heard of a lot,
Jim Watson and Francis Crick.
At the time that Avery made his
discovery reporting DNA was
transformation,
and Jim Watson described himself
later as a precocious college boy in
Chicago who was consumed
by ornithology.
So he was into bird watching.
That's what he was excited about at
the time Avery did his experiment.
And Francis Crick at that point was
a physicist, and he was in the
British Navy designing Navel mines.
So that's where those two players
were at the time of Avery's results.
So then both Francis Crick and Jim
Watson ended up in Cambridge,
England about 1950.
I think Crick got there around 1949
and Jim Watson got there in 1951.
Francis Crick was a grad student,
35 years old at the time.  I'll show
you pictures in a minute.
35 years old at the time and still
working on his PhD.
So he was a pretty elderly grad
student, if you want to think of it
that way.  And Jim Watson
was a young hot-shot.
He had done his PhD working with
Salvador Luria who was at Indiana
University at the time.
Salvador Luria was one of the Nobel
Laureates at MIT.
He founded the Cancer Center,
which is still here right across
from the main biology building.
And Jim was a very, very bright and
brash young guy,
and he had done his PhD with Salva
and then he went to Cambridge as
well.  And the reason they both went
to Cambridge was they were attracted
by the power of x-ray
crystallography.
Now, I said a little work about that
earlier, that if you take x-rays and
you bounce them off a crystal and
then measure the diffraction pattern
you can work backwards by Fourier
transforms and whatnot to figure out
what the underlying crystal
structure is.  For the purposes of
this course the mechanics of how
that's done, we don't have to worry
about that right now.
You just need to know that you can
work backwards from the diffraction
pattern to figure out what the
underlying structure was.
And I told you,
when I introduced to proteins,
that the first clues that there were
these regions of secondary structure,
alpha helices and beta sheets came
because people saw characteristic
reflections in these diffraction
patterns of certain proteins.
And I also told you the story of
how Linus Pauling had gone to Oxford,
had gotten sick and tired of reading
detective novels,
started to try and explain the
refractions in a certain class of
proteins and came up with a model
for the alpha helix.
And so that was the sort of thing
that inspired Watson and Crick.
They were both interested in when
one could get the structure of DNA.
Now, Cambridge also had a very good
x-ray crystallogram group.
And just in passing it's
interesting as to why they didn't
come up with the structure of the
alpha helix.  There were two things.
One was just lack of basic
knowledge.
I told you that the peptide bond,
if you remember I emphasized that
you cannot rotate it because the
electrons are distributed.
Pauling was an outstanding chemist.
He knew that fact.  And the folks
at Cambridge who were doing that
didn't learn this until later,
so their models were far less
constrained because they could have
rotation around that bond.
And the other one was just an
experimental thing that the size of
the photographic plates they used in
the Cambridge lab were too small in
the sense that they missed a key
reflection that Pauling knew about
and they didn't know about.
So this combination led to them
being scooped by the other group.
But nevertheless the group at
Cambridge was absolutely outstanding
and at one of the top places in the
world to do.  And I showed you a
couple of pictures when I was
showing you the transition state.
Sort of what you get out of working
backwards from these diffraction
patterns is they can measure regions
of electron density,
and then you fit atoms or fit
molecules to the patterns that you
see.  And if it's all working you
can explain why there are bumps here.
There's an oxygen here and so on.
There's another one.  This is an
ATP that's bound actually in a
pocket in a protein.
But you can sort of see how
beautifully the patterns of electron
density deduced from the x-ray
crystallography will match the
chemical structures that we put on
the board.  So that was the idea,
they were going to work out the
structure of DNA.
Now, the thing about Watson and
Crick, who at this point looked like
this, they didn't look inordinately
distinguished.
In fact, Jim probably looked like,
you've probably seen people who look
approximately like that around MIT.
He would have fit in right here and
no one would have noticed.
They were not actually x-ray
crystallographers.
They were just trying to model
other people's data.
And the best DNA crystallography
data was a young woman Roselyn
Franklin who was working in London.
A very somewhat uneasy alliance with
Maurice Wilkins.
And in trying to read the history
it's a bit complicated because,
at least some of what I've read,
I think that when Roslyn Franklin
arrived at the lab she was told this
DNA structure problem was hers.
And Maurice Wilkins in whose lab
she was working was told that he was
sort of working for her.
So there was a bunch of confusion
in this.
But, in any case,
Roslyn Franklin was collecting
crystallographic data.
And Watson and Crick located some
distance away in Cambridge were
trying to come up with models that
could explain the structure of DNA.
And they learned about Roslyn's
data.  And it was here data that
they used to work out the basis,
her crystallographic data that they
used when they put together
their structure.
So if it hadn't been for her they
wouldn't have been able to make
their discovery.
So part of the reason I'm dwelling
on this is I think their discovery
of the structure of DNA was arguably
one of the great intellectual
advances of our time.
It just opened doors.
The whole field of molecular
biology became possible once people
suddenly saw that DNA was
complimentary strands.
You could almost immediately see
how you could copy genetic
information.
It laid the groundwork for what
later turned out to be,
you know, recombinant DNA and
everything else.
So much of this pivots around this
one discovery.
And I think I wouldn't be doing
justice to this finding,
which you all have heard about for
years and years,
if I had let you walk away from here
thinking this was too young geniuses
who sat down in a room with some
crystallographic data and emerged
with a structure that sort of
changed the course of the
study of biology.
And, as you can see,
changes our society and everything
else.  There are a couple of
accounts of this,
there are numerous accounts.
One that I found pretty interesting
is called ìThe Eighth Day of
Creation,î if you ever want to read
an interesting book on science.
This was Horace Judson's effort to
try and put together a history of
this happening.
And with all history he's
ultimately --
You know, there are some judgment
calls by the historian,
but this one certainly he tried to
be pretty fair-handed and
even-handed and he tried to get at
the heart of what was going on.
Watson wrote a book called ìThe
Double Helixî.
Jim Watson's a very colorful
character, quite brash particularly
when he was younger,
and that's reflected in this book.
It's an interesting read.  Probably
more balanced point of view for sure
in ìThe Eighth Day of Creationî.
And there are now a lot of other
books.  But what I did,
just to try and do this in about a
minute or two,
was I took a couple of the key
things that happened during their
adventure of trying to work out the
structure of DNA and just kind of
ran some of their missteps together,
because even though this was a
marvelous discovery it just didn't
happen.  So they started out,
they were inspired by Linus
Pauling's discovery of
the alpha helix.
And I don't know if you can remember
the story, but what Pauling decided
to do when he was lying in bed and
with a strip of paper trying to work
out the structure that was giving
these reflections in the crystal
structure, he said I'm going to
start by ignoring the side chains.
So that was a brilliant move in the
case of the alpha helix because he
was then able to figure out that
that hydrogen bond between the
carbonyl and the amino group,
you could see how if you got helix
going it would repeat at exactly the
way that would give the reflections
that were observed in
the crystallography.
So that was how Watson and Crick
sort of did it.
Linus Pauling had shown the way.
So they decided they would ignore
the side chains of DNA.
So they started out by saying we
won't consider the ATs,
the Gs and the Cs.  Well,
given what you know about the
structure of DNA that was not a
helpful move in trying to work out
the structure of DNA.
Another thing,
for example, that happened was that
Jim Watson has no lack of
self-confidence.
And so it turned out when he went
to hear scientific talks he didn't
take notes.  And so he went to hear
a talk on x-ray crystallography
given by Roslyn Franklin,
but he didn't quite remember the
numbers right.
He got the facts a little jumbled,
and he and Francis spent a while
trying to design models to data that
wasn't the right data.
It was just not quite remembered
right, so there was kind of an
inefficiency there.
And then Jim had a bias almost to
the end that the phosphate backbones
they knew would somehow be on the
inside and the bases would be on the
outside of the structure.
So if that's your sort of starting
place then it's sort of hard.
So Watson, excuse me,
Francis Crick was beginning to
suspect that maybe the bases were
important.  So he hired a young
mathematician.
And he said, ìCan you see if you
could work out whether there would
be any chemical attraction between
any pairs of bases?
And the young mathematician came
back and said that he thought G
might go with C and A with T.
And given what happened here you
might have thought that a light bulb
would have gone off,
but it didn't.  And, in fact,
Chargaff visited them and the light
bulb went off for nobody.
And, in fact, Chargaff wasn't a
terribly big fan of what Watson and
Crick were trying to do.
So the pieces are piling up but
still not there.
Then a big experimental advance
came from Roslyn Franklin.
And that was she discovered that the
DNA that they had been diffracting
was actually a mixture of two forms.
So there were actually two
structures in the mix that were
contributing to the diffractions.
She was able to separate out the
two kinds of DNA,
DNA-A and DNA-B she called it.
And so now this gave a much clearer
diffraction pattern,
and that's the diffraction pattern
that she saw.
And Watson and Crick managed to get
a look at this data.
And it's a little complicated how
that happened,
but Crick realized almost right away
that there were two strands running
in opposite directions.
So he know knew it was 5 to 3 in
one direction and 5 to 3 in the
other direction like that.
So you might have thought they were
home-free, but no.
Jim Watson immediately built a
model that paired like with like,
A with A, T with T, G with G.  They
wrote it up and they were ready to
submit the paper.
And they gave a presentation to
their colleagues at the lab in
Cambridge.  And they were shot down.
And one of the key things was they
learned the chemical fact that most
of the textbooks were wrong at that
time in the way that they depicted
the structure of guanine.
If you look in your textbook,
excuse me, here.
So if you were to look in a textbook
today you'd see guanine like this,
but there is another way you could
draw this.
So this you may remember when we
were talking about
phosphoenolpyruvate that this is an
enol form and this is a keto form.
And this is the way most of the
textbooks were showing guanine at
the time.  So they were looking at
the structure of guanine in
textbooks.  And if you were trying
to work out schemes for putting
bases together you can see what's
going on up here would be very
different.  And if we have a
hydrogen here versus if we have an
oxygen, if you're trying to say make
hydrogen bonds at that particular
position, I think all of you
understand hydrogen bonds well
enough to see how that
would throw you off.
So once that insight came,
once they learned that then the rest
of the structure came pretty fast.
And there's a movie about this.
One of the nice things in it was
sort of trying to recreate the
experience where I think it was
Watson who was shuffling these base
pairs around.  And he suddenly
realized that you could set up base
pairs with A and T and with G and C,
and when you looked at them you
could see they were geometrically
exactly the same shape.
You could just take the shape of the
G and C pair and lay it right down
on the A and T pair.
And then you could see how you
could build either a G-C or an A-T
pair into the repeating structure of
this DNA and it would be compatible.
So they built a model and they
thought, we can just hit the lights
for a second here maybe.
I just want you to see what that
first model looked like.
It looks like something you could
hack together in a chemistry lab.
They had the bases cut out of metal.
And you can see just,
you know, here the retort sort of
stands using chemistry and various
clamps that you would use for
clamping a flask or something if
you're doing a chemical lab.
That's the stuff that they were
using to put the model together.
And they published then a paper in
Nature that told about this result.
That's the entire paper reporting
the structure of DNA.
And maybe you can see there's a
little hand-drawn double helix right
there that captures the elements.
That is the paper, and that was in
the journal Nature.
And it had in it, right near the
end, one of the coyest sentences in
the scientific literature.
They didn't want to go into all the
details that if you had an A paired
with G and G paired with a C and you
pulled them apart then you could
replicate the molecule by redoing it.
So all they said was,
ìIt has not escaped our notice that
the specific pairings we
expostulated immediately suggests a
copying mechanism for DNA.
So this is a picture of Jim Watson
wearing short pants at Cold Spring
Harbor in 1953 reporting
this structure of DNA.
Cold Spring Harbor is on Long Island.
It's been one of the Meccas for
molecule biology since the 1940s.
They have a famous symposium once a
year.  The topic changes every year
and rarely repeats.
And it was at one of those symposia
--
This was the year that they
discovered the structure of DNA.
And there was Watson.  So two years
ago they had another meeting,
a special meeting just exactly this
time of year.  It was in February
within a couple of days of right now.
So I gave this lecture and I showed
the student in the class that this
year, I said here's a picture of Jim
Watson displaying the structure.
They're having a meeting 50 years
later in 2003.
And I'm going down there.
I'm asked to give a talk.
And I'll come back and I'll tell
you what it was like.
So I gave my lecture.
I dashed out to the airport.
I hoped on the plane.  I went down
and I registered.
They gave me, you know,
the stuff to get into my room,
a little envelope with the key card
and things.  And I went up to my
room.  And I took out the key card.
And what did I find myself looking
at?  The same picture I had shown to
the class just a couple
of hours earlier.
Here's another picture of Jim the
way he looked at the time when he
made this amazing discovery.
That's Salvador Luria who I
mentioned.  I tell you about him in
a subsequent lecture.
I was at another meeting a few
years earlier where some of the
old-timers were razzing each other,
and someone showed this picture.
And then they got up and they gave
it a title.  And that was ìPicture
of a Man Picking His Own Pocketsî.
So they would tease each other a lot.
And I'm hoping maybe you'll get a
chance to hear a little bit
more about that soon.
This is what Jim Watson looks like
now.  I asked to get a picture taken
just so you could see he's still
around and is very active and still
very controversial.
This doesn't make much of a
difference.  Here's a picture of
Watson and Crick a little bit later
just sitting out on a porch in Cold
Spring Harbor.
It's sort of right on the edge of a
bay down there in a very relaxed
kind of atmosphere that still
permeates molecule biology
research to this day.
Francis Crick just died last July at
the age of 88,
so we've just lost the link to one
of the two people who did this
amazing experiment.
OK.  So I want to then set things
up for the details of DNA
replication.  So there was a basic
principle that came across from this
that you could see how this could
work, that DNA was sort of like
having a photograph and a negative.
And so the information is actually
in there twice.
It's just in different forms.
And when I tell you about DNA
repair in another lecture you can
maybe see already how useful that is
because if you damage one strand
you're not really out of luck
because you've still got the
information in the other strand.
And you could probably,
on the basis of that, device a
repair strategy if you thought about
it.  But more importantly for DNA
replication finally gave an insight
to this thing that had been vexing
people forever.
If you had to have all this
information for making a cell,
and every time a cell divided and
you saw how it can happen pretty
quickly with something like a
bacterium of yeast,
how could you accurately copy all
that DNA, excuse me,
all that genetic information?
How is it stored?
How could it be done?
And once you saw ah, it's just a
matter of separating the strands,
and if there's an A there put a T
there, if there's a C you put a G
and so on, was a huge breakthrough.
But that then didn't tell people
how DNA replicated or even if this
is the mechanism.
You can actually come up with all
kinds of models for how you could
replicate things based on this
principle, including crisscrossing
between strands and all
sorts of things.
The predominant model and perhaps
the simplest one was called
semi-conservative.
And it thought of the problem in
this kind of way,
that if you had two strands of the
original DNA molecule and then you
pulled them apart that one of the
strands here would become one of the
strands of the daughter,
and then the new one would be here
and the same thing would happen on
the other side.
And then if you did it again this
thing would happen again with a new
strand.  This time the skinny strand
here would be like this,
the skinny strand here would be like
this, and then this one again.
We'd have one that was nearly
synthesized plus one of the
originals.  So this model was one of
the simplest because it kept this
strand intact throughout the whole
process while some of the other
models had them being patched back
together, all based on the idea that
A pairs with T and G pairs with C.
But proving that this was the
correct model was then another
important advance.
And that was done by Frank Stahl and
Matt Meselson.
Actually, I think I'll skip this
for right now.
Matt is a professor up at Harvard,
just up at Harvard Square not very
far from here,
still very active.
Frank Stahl is a professor out in
Oregon.  He's still active.
So one of the differences about
this course is a lot of the things
I'm telling you about --
And this is pretty old stuff right
now, right, molecule biology.
The people who did these are still
around and very active.
This is most of modern biology is a
pretty young scientist,
and many of the major characters are
still running around and with us
today.  So, anyway,
what Matt and Frank were at Caltech.
And they with a bunch of other
students had an apartment.
And they were sitting around trying
to work out a way to figure out this
model.  And they came up with an
idea, and that was to see if you
could differentially label what we
might call ìold DNAî and the ìnew
DNAî here.  And since it's
chemically the same stuff it's a bit
of a trick.  How do you tell old DNA
from new DNA?
So their idea was since nitrogen
comes in two different isotopes,
N14 which is the common one and N15
with is one mass heavier,
that maybe you could start out with
the DNA, for example,
grown in N15.  And then when you
started replication switch to N14.
And then you'd be able to tell,
if you could separate these
molecules on the basis of their
density since the one with the N15
would be heavier than the one with
the N14, then maybe you could work
this out.  And the story goes,
this has been written, they were
sitting arguing about this,
or talking about this idea at the
table.  And it was a good idea but
there was a problem.
And that was how could you separate
the two kinds of DNA based
on their density?
So they had a piece of fingernail
and they were trying to see whether
they could get it to float by
dissolving more and more sugar.
And they figured if they added more
and more sugar the water would get
denser and denser so the could float
the fingernail.
And they weren't able to do it.
But all chemists made a periodic,
probably some places here at MIT,
they had a periodic chart right in
their living room.
So they went and they looked.
And then they looked at sodium.
And they went down the periodic
table and then they saw cesium.
And thought maybe,
you know, if you took a solution of
cesium chloride and you put it a
centrifuge and you spun really hard
then you'd get a gradient of varying
concentrations,
of slightly different concentrations
of cesium chloride.
And that they could tune that to a
range that would discriminate
between the heavy and the lighter
forms of DNA.  So the experiment
they did is known as the
Meselson-Stahl experiment.
But, as I say, these are names that
come from real people.
And the idea was pretty simple.
They grew the bacteria for many
generations --
-- in N15 medium.
This is the so-called heavy
or H isotope --
-- of nitrogen.
And then that time equals zero in
their experiment,
when they're ready to start the
experiment they switched to medium
with N14, which we'll think of as
the light or the L isotope.
And then they isolated DNA --
-- after let's say increasing rounds
of replication that you could tell
simply by measuring how much DNA was
in your bacterial culture when the
bacteria had doubled their DNA.
And this is the data they got which
looks something like this.
In fact, in this case the
blackboard representation is pretty
close.  So this is cesium chloride.
And it has been centrifuged very
hard so that there's a gradient now
that's light at the top and a little
heavier at the bottom
of the gradient.
There's a little more cesium
chloride per mil here then there is
there in the tube.
And I'll just give us three little
sort of reference marks here.
So what they found when they
started was that all of the DNA was
at that position down
at the heavy end.
And then this is after one
generation.  So the DNA has now
doubled.  What they found was that
all the DNA was now at this
intermediate position.
And after two generations or two DNA
replications they now found that
some of the DNA was here,
some of the DNA was there.
And if they went to three or more
what they saw was they began to pile
stuff up there.
And I think most of you could
probably make the connection between
that data and that picture that I've
got up there.  This is
the heavy-heavy DNA.
This is the heavy-light.
So this would be heavy-heavy,
heavy-light, light-heavy.  After one
round it will all be here.
After two we have heavy-light,
but this one is light-light,
light-light, light-heavy.
And so now we've got light-light,
the heavy-light, no heavy-heavy is
ever going to show up again.
And the longer you do this the more
you'll get the light accumulating.
A very simple experiment done by
real people but enormously powerful
because now it showed that this
basic idea, you have the photograph
and negative, you pull them apart
and copy them was right.
So at this point you begin to see
why data of Avery's that before
people had trouble accepting,
all of a sudden now it was really
you needed a CYD and A was
the genetic material.
And this is what sort of ushered in
this great burst of molecular
biology.  So in the next lecture
what we're going to start doing now
is once you, this is all great,
but once we start figuring out how
to replicate it we're going to have
to get down to enzymes and
biochemical steps.
And there are some formidable
challenges to replicating DNA,
and it's also awesome.  I'll tell
you at the beginning of next lecture
how much DNA we have and just
how accurate it is.
It always blows me away.
I'll see you then.  Take care.